welcome back to new rock stars I'm Gina
iolo and this is a breakdown of the
giggle the third and final episode of
the Doctor Who 60th anniversary specials
Eric is on paternity leave and as the
resident Doctor Who nerd at who rock
stars I'm filling in for this Russell T
Davis penned episode which was a fitting
end for a fan favorite doctor and
companion and a fabulous introduction to
15th doctor shuti gatwa so let's break
this down for all the Easter eggs
references and ominous lingering threats
left hanging in the air we open in SoHo
in 1925 as a man walks into the Mr
Emporium toy store the camera pushes in
on the glass lingering on the words
tricks and games giving us a glimpse of
what we'll be getting this episode Neil
Patrick Harris shows up right away as
the toy maker a role he's clearly having
a ton of fun with starting out with an
over-the-top German accent throughout
the episode he Cycles through French
English and his own American accent he
mentions the game Snakes and Ladders
this was brought to the UK from India in
the 1890s and then Milton Bradley
started selling it under the name Shoots
and Ladders in the US in the 40s he says
on they are very very important and
these rules don't you think we find out
later that the rules of the game bind
the the toymaker's entire existence so
he's setting up their importance early
on so a bit of character history the toy
maker was initially introduced in the
first doctor Story the celestial toy
maker he was played then by Michael Goff
the doctor and his companions Steven and
dodo are abducted into the realm of the
toy maker who was eternal and super
powerful and really liked playing games
with anyone he could trap the three of
them surviv the games and Escape in the
Tardis before the toymaker's realm
disappears three of the original four
episodes of this serial were lost but
the audio survives which they're using
to animate the missing bits and we see
some of the surviving footage later on
in this episode Charlie tells the toy
maker he wants to buy this doll stooky
Bill and holy crap is he terrifying he's
surrounded by his doll wife stooky Sue
and three stookie babies who are all
just the stuff of nightmares the
toymaker is famous for threatening to
turn people into toys which he does in
this episode and also in some Books and
Comics so it's possible that the stooky
bill doll used to be a living person who
lost a game and that would be extra
horrifying given that he has this family
which would mean the toym maker
basically killed them all pleasant
dreams everyone Charlie asks if the hair
on the doll is real something that they
actually used to do on occasion and the
toymaker responds that it is and he cut
it off the head of a beautiful lady but
she wouldn't miss it and dude Charlie
run the toym maker does this very creepy
laugh that becomes a major plot point
and is the titular giggle of the
episode he wraps the doll up in brown
paper the same kind that Charlie is
wrapped up in later and we get a good
look at this creepy doll behind him
whose mouth is open in a Perpetual
scream Charlie says he works for John
loie be he was a real life Scottish
inventor who introduced the television
to the world in 1926 using as the first
image he transmitted the head of a
triloquist dummy named stooky Bill so
you can see where this is going back in
Beard's Workshop the image of bill on
the TV is giving me very distinct jigsaw
Vibes Charlie asks him how hot it is
under the lights and beard says that's
why we need sticky Bill no man could sit
underneath that temperature and poor
Bill's head starts to melt and this is
all based on what actually happened be
had to use a lot of lights to light the
subject and the hair of the doll did
actually singe and its plaster cracked
but be also chose to use a painted doll
with a high contrast face because he was
worried that human faces wouldn't have
enough contrast for their features to be
picked up by the photo electric cell as
stooky Bill catches fire mouth a gape we
hear the repeated giggle that takes us
into the opening credits and then we're
back in the present day right after the
events of the ending of wild blue yonder
with chaos in the streets we see people
looting screaming at each other driving
all over the place there's even a pickup
truck forcibly pushing a car up the
street it's driver honking frantically
and as the doctor walks through it all
taking it in we see the toy maker now
looking very Cabaret in the background
dancing around a guy holding a the end
is nigh sign a man explains to the
doctor that 2 days ago everyone started
thinking they're right all the time and
who boy we are in for some good old
Russell T Davis commentary on Modern
Times And I'm here for it the toy maker
now doing a French accent tries to get
the doctor to dance with him and again I
just love how much fun Neil Patrick
Harris is having with all this chaos
around him Donna stands off to the side
with her Granddad in his wheelchair but
they're careful not to show his face
that's because Bernard cribbons passed
away before he was able to film anything
for this episode when unit shows up we
hear his voice say the doctor that's
actually cribbons audio reused from the
season 4 episode the poison Sky don't
listen to her
you go with the doctor unit uses a
helicopter to tow the Tardis something
we also saw on the Day of the Doctor the
50th anniversary special when the 11th
drct and clar were actually still inside
unit headquarters is looking
distinctively Avengers Towery now with
its own helipad and everything they
might want to rethink this design scheme
since it didn't work out too well for
The Avengers unit scientific adviser
shirlean Bingham greets them in 14 says
Johnny you can't be serious a noge the
movie Airplane surely you can't be
serious I am serious and don't call me
shirely Kate left brid Stewart joins
them and the doctor says I remember your
father working night and day to keep
units secret and look at you now but
she's just out here in public defending
the Earth her dad Brigadier Le Bridge
Stewart played by Nicholas Courtney
first popped up in a second doctor story
he then became close friends with the
third doctor and appeared in at least 23
episodes of the original run his final
appearance was in a Seventh Doctor
episode and the 11th doctor learned of
his death in the wedding of River Song
he was one of only a few close friends
the doctor invited to see him before his
supposed death the Brigadier also later
got resurrected as a Cyberman and
finally got some cloes osure on their
relationship even getting a much desired
salute from the 12th doctor Kate says
robots and insects and yetis and clones
but what do we do this time doctor okay
so the robots she mentions are probably
the Cyberman with the 12th doctor and
death in heaven the after mentioned
episode with her dad as a Cyberman
insects might be the RAR Warriors from
the first special the star Beast Yeti
this is kind of a deep cut but I think
she came into contact with yetis during
the 1995 spin-off downtime clones is a
reference to The zygon Invasion and the
Osgood doubles the doctor is handed some
Intel by none other than Mel played by
Bonnie Langford Melanie Bush companion
of Colin Baker's sixth doctor and
Sylvester McCoy's 7th she showed up
briefly in the support group scene in
power of the doctor but now she's
properly back it seems Mel was a
computer programmer from the 20th
century and who fans weren't huge on her
but she was pppy and positive and had
big curly hair so I felt to kinship with
her at the end of season 24 when Ace is
introduced in dragon fire Mel goes off
with a mercenary named sabalom Glitz to
keep him in line during his Space
Adventures because of a lot of
convoluted stuff going on with the show
and the BBC at the time Mel is one of
the only companions who never got an
orig story in terms of how she started
traveling with the doctor you could
argue Susan the doctor's granddaughter
never got one either but carolan Ford
the actress who played her has said she
doesn't consider Susan a companion don't
come at me in the comments I'm just
repeating what she said Mel's send off
was also kind of abrupt due to Colin
Baker leaving the role before the show
could go back and film their meeting Mel
isn't the first of the doctor's exoman
to take a job with unit and we later see
that she won't be the last Donna
expresses her dislike of the term
companion and asks I wasn't the first
redhead the doctor has also traveled
with redhead Amy Pond and several times
he expressed a desire to be Ginger after
regenerating we get a little bit of
exposition about what's going on and why
everyone in the world is so angry we
meet the vinkx who created the Zex which
allows the wearer to be unaffected by
the brain Spike causing everyone to go
all Alex Jones throwing a fit Kate
deactivates hers in order to show the
doctor what they're dealing with and
then we get a surprising but absolutely
delightful Cameo from Trinity Wells
played by lelle Carl from 2005 to 2010
when Davis was showrunner Wells always
popped up on TV reporting on news
anytime there was alien activity she
also appeared at Torchwood and the Sarah
Jane Adventures making her one of the
few actors who's appeared as the same
character in all three shows fans were
thrilled to see Wells again since she
was always a favorite Shirley says that
the coat the satellite that two days ago
gave internet access to every person on
earth is clean and there's nothing
hiding in the signal like there was in
the old Archangel Network that was the
network used for mind control to help
the Harold Saxon Master get elected
Donna figures out that the Seven Peaks
in the wavelength Spike are musical
notes she really is brilliant and I love
watching Tate shine and Mel adds that
it's a classic arpeggio they discover
the giggle in everyone's head hiding in
the image of stooky bill on the TV the
doctor says that this manipulation
doesn't let the human race off the hook
all the anger out there on the street
the lies the righteousness that's human
that's you this type of speech is where
tenant and Doctor Who Have Always shined
holding a mirror up to society even as
we prepare to go online and spew more
vital perhaps about this very episode
the toymaker's plan of infecting screens
with an evil doll reminds me of the 10th
doctor episode the idiots Lantern in
which an evil electrical alien known as
the wire is using TVs to steal people's
energy so it can regrow its body there
was also a story written for the 1986
season of Doctor Who that never aired
called the nightmare fair that would
have shown the toym maker creating an
arcade game that sucks up The Souls of
its players a novelization of that
script was eventually released the
doctor gives unit his permission to use
their galvanic beam to take out the
satellite he can do this because he was
inducted as president of Earth in death
in heaven he catches up with Mel who
Smiles a huge smile when he calls her
brilliant which I just love she traveled
with sabalom Glitz until he died at 101
by tripping over a whiskey bottle a very
fitting end for him Kate offers donana a
job at unit for 60,000 a year 120 plus 5
weeks holiday
done I love Donna so much she and the
doctor head to Soho in 1925 and we get
this cool shot from down the alley of
the TARDIS materializing and you can see
the interior as they exit they're making
use of those bigger budgets by trying
some new stuff Donna mentions Mel who
she likes a lot which is in keeping with
her attitude when she met Martha Jones
the doctor was worried at the time that
the women would be jealous of one
another like rose and Sarah Jane were
when they first met Donna mentioning
that the doctor has never brought up Mel
is both in character but serves to
remind is that since she wasn't one of
the more popular companions she was sort
of left out of reminiscences over the
years as Donna gives this speech about
the doctor wearing himself out Tenon
actually does show his age he hasn't
shaved he looks a bit Haggard and he's
definitely got more lines on his face
than we remember the toy maker plays
peek-aboo with 14 as he looks in the
shop and starts juggling as they enter
again Neil Patrick hair is showing off
one of his many skills he says that the
ball is the first game ever invented
setting up the climactic Ball Toss later
we get to see colorized footage from the
classic era Celestial toy maker and this
is the first time we hear his name
uttered in this episode The Toy Maker
then we get another arpeggio giggle from
the toy maker as he hides this long
hallway but the nisp doors reminds me of
the Minotaur hotel in the God complex
with each door hiding something
terrifying Donna touches on some of
their adventures together saying she's
seen UD Davos and the atos but this is
something different she asks what the
toy maker is and 14 responds when I was
young I was so sure of myself I met a
terrible M I know I just said that he's
showing his age but it's funny to hear
the perpetually boyish tenant talk about
William hartel's doctor being young
since he looked exceedingly older
although yes obviously in the world of
the show the first doctor was at least
hundreds of millions of years younger
than 14 a mysterious Vault teach do you
mean what danger and wonder has opened
are you ready to embark on this secret
journey to explore the relics and ruins
now Magic the Gathering is letting you
take on the role of legendary Explorer L
coft with their new secret lair
collaboration this secret lair drop is
awesome it's got fan favorite cards like
Shadow Spear and Academy ruins with Tomb
Raider inspired Art Plus an allnew
mechanically unique Laura Croft Tomb
Raider card this drop is available
exclusively through the secret lair
website it's got six cards total plus a
treasure token and even better the
secret layer Tomb Raider drop is
available now just click the link in the
description below and get yours today
the toym maker was led into reality This
Time by 14 casting salt at the edge of
the universe in wild blue yonder
something he was worried would come back
to bite him in the butt I invoked a
Superstition at the edge of the universe
in true who fashion the doctor and Donna
get separated and he encounters Charlie
who lost a game to the toy maker and was
turned into a puppet meanwhile Donna
enters a room inhabited by stooky su who
speaks in terrifying Rhymes he won't
come home to me cuz they bur him on TV
and this stooky babes who descend from
the ceiling like spiders but Donna just
faed down the not things at the end of
the universe so she has got it handled
she smashes the Widow and threatens the
babies and I could just watch Donna kick
ass and spout off on liners all day my
name's Donna now I think that you're GNA
she's reunited with the doctor and the
toymaker theater which kind of gave me
Coraline Vibes when she's in the theater
in the other mother's realm the toymaker
puts on a puppet show featuring the
stories of Amy Pond Clara Oswald Bill
pots and the flux so I'll run through
all those real quick and super basic
Strokes not going to go into all the
details and nuances Amy Pond's husband
Rory was sent back in time by the touch
of a weeping angel they feed off the
time of those they've displaced and so
Amy turned her back to the same Angel
begging it to send her to be with Rory
the doctor couldn't cross her timeline
so he never saw her again but she did
write to him using the prologue of a
book she knew he'd read Clara flew off
with a shielder aka me her last second
of Life Frozen after the events of face
the Raven when she transferred someone
else's death sentence to herself she
will eventually need to go back to galr
to actually die the doctor's memories of
his time with her were wiped but then he
ultimately got them back bill got turned
into a Cyberman but didn't realize it
Heather woman Bill had a connection with
who then got turned into like a sentient
oil slick thing came back for her and
turned her into the same oil slick like
thing and then they took off together so
a version of Bill still exists out there
the flux was the universe wide
apocalypse from 13's time the companions
of the modern era especially the Moffet
years often faced much worse Fates than
earlier companions in the classic era a
lot of them just left like Mel or they
went home like Sarah Jane Ian and Barbra
one of them dying like when adric
sacrificed himself was incredibly rare
but in the modern era the doctor has
faced a lot of loss the past few years
and this show really hammers that home
the mention of all of those tragedies
also successfully baits the doctor into
challenging the toy maker they face off
like Gunslingers at High Noon and we get
to see Harris do some close-up card
tricks it's really awesome seeing these
two play off of each other the toymaker
speaks of all those he's played games
with saying he gambled with God and
turned him into a Jack In The Box so the
toymaker's background in Doctor Who has
always been a bit murky in his Original
Episode it seemed like he was being set
up to be one of the then unnamed Race of
Time Lords but since then depending on
the doctor there have been different
explanations ranging from just just a
nameless entity to one of the Guardians
Of Time who were Masters of Reality that
predate the creation of the universe and
in some cases are the same species as
God although they too seem to have
different properties depending on the
media being referenced we've seen some
Guardians before in episodes like the
Armageddon factor and Enlightenment it
was cool and weird and reminds me of the
Portlandia sketch put a bird on it later
on the toy maker says he played against
the Guardians and shrank them into
voodoo dolls anyway it's definitely
possible that the toy maker did meet God
or a God and bested them in a game he
then says the master was dying I sealed
him for all eternity inside my gold
tooth we last saw the master as the Spy
master in the power of the doctor where
he tried to regenerate into the doctor
he was thwarted crushed by a boulder and
left to die on a planet that was about
to explode so I'm guessing that this is
when he tried to play a game with the
toy maker and lost he continues there's
only one player I didn't dare face the
one who Waits I'll get into some
theories on this a little later the toym
maker and the doctor decide to cut cards
and the doctor loses the character on
the king card the toy maker turns over
looks like the original toy maker from
the classic run the doctor points out
that they're technically tied since the
last time time they met he was the
winner and then the set starts
collapsing in on itself in this super
cool effect the whole Toy Store folds up
into the box that they later used to put
the toy maker in in a deep Vault bounded
salt somewhere where I assume the Arc of
the Covenant is also stored the galvanic
beam takes out the satellite and then we
get probably my favorite scene of the
whole episode in the middle of the
doctor giving a very doctory speech he's
interrupted by the Spice Girls spice up
your life and as someone who went to the
theater to see Spice World opening
weekend I was very excited by this the
toymaker enters the scene like a
Broadway hurricane reminding me of the
Master's Rasputin routine in power of
the doctor he lip syns he dances he
turns bullets into rose pedals he kills
people by turning them into colorful
balls and then he disappears with a
flourish and a clown horn honk and just
shoot this straight into my eyeballs
forever the toymaker hijacks the beam
and the doctor tries to convince him to
come travel the stars with him we can
be Celestial an obvious nod to the title
of the original cereal but the toy maker
turns him down preferring Earth's humans
in all the games they play and then he
shoots 14 the doctor starts radiating
regeneration energy and Donna and Mel
each take one of his hand hands this
music starts playing that was the same
music that played over the ninth
doctor's regeneration and then Mel says
cuz every single one of you is fantastic
fantastic that was one of Nine's
favorite catchphrases 14 says here we go
again which was what Brigadier
Lethbridge Stewart said in Planet of the
spiders when three was regenerating and
he also says feels different this time
which was what the fifth doctor said
when he was regenerating that was
actually Peter Davidson David tenant's
father-in-law he says his catchphrase
Alon Z meaning let's go which contrasts
with I don't want to go which is what
number 10 says the last time this
happened and then we get the moment that
everyone has been talking about since
this aired the first ever by generation
as Donna and Mel each pull an arm 15
splits out of 14 we get another round of
what what what away and then shoy gwa
starts cooking he immediately brings a
ton of joy and energy to the roll as the
camera spins up and around them this
plot Point literally upending all the
lore we thought we knew 15 wastes no
time in setting himself apart he tells
14 to push and then they separate each
wearing half the other one's clothes
with 14 wearing the undershirt vest and
pants and 15 wearing the button-up tie
sneakers and underwear and sorry to
point out the obvious but this means
that 14 is currently going commando Mel
tells 15 he's beautiful and he really is
you guys both doctors challenge the toy
maker and they play the first game catch
the three have a grand old time throwing
and running and bending and snapping and
eventually the toy maker loses and is
banished from existence folding in on
himself and getting shut up in his box
but not before saying this my Legions
are coming 15 and tell a contemplative
14 that he can't save everyone and the
deaths aren't his fault and then 15
gives him the most healing hug you'll
ever see come here I've got you there's
even a little kiss on the forehead
that's so cute the gold tooth containing
the master is picked up by hand with red
nail polish and we hear the audio of
multiple incarnations of Master voices
layered over one
another 15 convinces 14 that it's time
to rest and work on himself by bringing
up just some of the stuff he's been
through they mention address River Song
Sarah Jane being gone Rose the time War
Pandora mavic Chen and the gods of
Ragnarok okay here we go how fast can I
speed through these put on trial is from
trial of a Time Lord the sixth doctor
was put on trial for breaking the laws
of galif fray but in the end he was
found not guilty it was number six's
last cereal before regenerating exiled
refers to the second doctor being exiled
by the time Lords and forced to
regenerate lopis was the name of a cal
and Planet visited by the fourth doctor
the doctor and the master team up to
stop the universe unraveling but the
master ultimately betrays him causing
number four to fall from great height
and regenerate adri was a companion of
the fourth and fifth doctor he
sacrificed himself on board a ship that
collided with Earth and killed the
dinosaurs River Song one of my favorite
characters has a whole long backstory
but is ultimately the child of Rory and
Amy Pond who was trained to assassinate
the doctor but eventually became his
wife Sarah Jane Smith was a favorite
companion who got her own spin-off the
Sarah Jane Adventures and passed away a
few years ago the time war was a massive
war fought by the eighth and War doctors
against the dollx the doctor thought it
resulted in the death of both time Lords
and dollx but both parties managed to
survive the Pandora was a cube prison
meant to trap the do doctor it did trap
11 but he managed to escape by creating
a Time Paradox mavic Chen was an enemy
of the first doctor he was a politician
titled guardian of the solar system and
sided with the dollx Against Humanity
until they eventually killed him the
gods of Ragnarok were supremely powerful
beings known as old ones they ran a
psychic circus and forced people to
perform for their entertainment the
Seventh Doctor was able to turn their
power against them and destroy their
physical connection to our universe okay
so 14 tells 15 that despite all of that
15 seems fine and 15 says I'm fine
because you fix yourself to me this
indicates that despite the by generation
and everything we don't know about it 14
will still eventually regenerate into 15
Donna tells the doctor that she can help
him stay in one place and just live the
one Adventure he's never had he changed
his face then he came and found her and
she knows why the only sticking point is
that the doctor could never let the
Tardis go his one constant through all
the years but 15 has a fix for that too
he uses the toy Maker's malet to create
a second Taris out of the first and 14
is officially out of excuses 15 tries to
take off without saying goodbye but 14
knows his tricks they hug and salute one
another before 15 kicks everyone out of
his Tardis and flies off into space and
14 stays put with his family mostly he's
definitely been stealing off with Mel
and donic on the odd Adventure I just
love this ending so much my takea away
from this is that even someone like the
Doctor Who's millions of years old can
learn to fix himself and grow and
appreciate everything he has that's a
powerful message and despite thinking
he'd be endlessly bored 14 says I've
never been so happy in my life now I've
seen some people arguing that the doctor
already had a family has had families
Susan Amy and Rory other companions but
in my mind this is all about how those
other iterations of the doctor weren't
ready to settle down but now with
everything he's been through he finally
is for a bit at least so some strings
left dangling I guess we're just waiting
now for the toy makers Legions to show
up it would be awesome to see 15
fighting off a bunch of sentient toys
but maybe there are other Legions I'm
not thinking of we still don't know who
the meeps boss is that was mentioned in
the starbeast but I'm guessing that
that's going to be the same as the one
who Waits that the toy maker mentioned
there are a few theories out there on
who this might be the eternals Omega Ash
shilder even Amy or Rory since they both
were the ones who waited at some point I
think it's a whole new big bad original
creation of Russell T Davis though also
who picked up the master in the gold
tooth Kate Lethbridge Stewart had red
nails similar to the ones on the hand
that we saw but I'm really hoping that
this is the hand of the Ronnie who I'd
love to see return from the classic Who
Days up next will be the 2023 Christmas
special which will be Shy's first proper
episode of the doctor and the trailer
looks like a freaking Delight so I'm
very excited about that let me know in
the comments if you are to and what you
thought of the Doctor Who 60th
anniversary specials thank you so much
to the awesome Noah Chen for helping
research and write this episode follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at G ippy
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
bye